sólo por el caso de que necesites ayuda
con la planeación de una fiesta de algún
rey
vamos a intentar resolver este tipo de
sistemas por nosotros mismos y aquí
tengo resuelve para x y usando el método
de eliminación o el de suma resta y
tengo dos ecuaciones menos 4 x + 2 y
igual a 12 menos 5 x menos 2 igual a
menos 30 y aquí tenemos que poner la
respuesta así que para esto voy a traer
aquí nuestra nuestro bloc de notas voy a
tener aquí nuestro pizarrón y vamos a
trabajar lo dice resuelve para x y para
ello usando eliminación y si te das
cuentas unas mismas ecuaciones de hace
rato menos 4 x + 2 y igual a 12 y es más
déjame irlas escribiendo aquí para poder
trabajar las menos 4 menos 4 x ok más
dos más dos veces y esto es igual a 12
ok y la otra está de verde así que
cambiamos el color verde y dice menos 5
x menos 5 x
dos veces y esto es igual a menos
treinta de lujo ahora ya tengo aquí un
sistema de ecuaciones con dos ecuaciones
y dos incógnitas pero como nos piden que
usemos el método de eliminación o el
método de suma y resta lo que quiero que
veas es que si nosotros sumamos estas
dos ecuaciones de una manera rapidísima
se cancelaría el 2 bien el 2 y menos 2
james esto se va y solamente me quedaría
algo que tiene que ver con términos de x
así que hagámoslo qué te parece si
sumamos estas dos ecuaciones vamos a
sumar esto y vamos a sumar esto ahora
seguramente me vas a decir porque
podemos sumar estas dos ecuaciones y
recuerda que eso se puede hacer porque
esta ecuación de abajo me está diciendo
que menos 5 x menos 2 james
esto es exactamente lo mismo que menos
30 es lo que me dice la segunda ecuación
la ecuación de aquí abajo entonces
realmente lo que estoy haciendo es sumar
menos 30 de ambos lados de la ecuación
de este lado voy a sumar menos 30 porque
sabemos que menos 30 es lo mismo que
menos 5 x 2 james
el lado derecho voy a restar 30 que es
exactamente lo mismo que menos 30 de
lujo y ahora pues vamos a sumar estas
dos ecuaciones y que me va a quedar
menos 4 x menos 5 y bueno eso es lo
mismo que menos 4 menos 5 por x y esos
menos 9 menos 9 x ok más 2 james 2 james
estos dos se cancelan ok y me queda
simple y sencillamente del lado derecho
12 menos 30 ok lo cual es lo mismo que
30 menos 12 con signo negativo
30 - 12 es 18 con signo negativo menos
18 ok y ahora necesitamos de esta
cuestión de aquí abajo menos 9 x es
igual a menos 18 despejará x y para eso
que te parece si divido a ambos lados de
esta ecuación entre menos 9 esta parte
entre menos 9 esta parte también entre
menos 9 de tal manera que me va a quedar
que x es exactamente lo mismo estos dos
se van y del lado derecho me queda menos
18 entre menos 9 lo cual es 2
de lujo - entre -10 y 89 veces 2 y ya
tengo el valor de x perfecto bastante
bien que nos sirve para encontrar este
sistema de ecuaciones pero ten cuidado
no hemos terminado nos falta encontrar
el valor de james y para eso puede
utilizar la ecuación de arriba la
ecuación de abajo para obtener el valor
de james y yo creo que en la ecuación de
arriba va a ser mucho más fácil me
quedaría menos 4 que multiplica a x ok a
x esto más 2 james a mercy más dos veces
james esto es igual a 12 pero nosotros
ya sabemos cuánto vale x x vale 2 por lo
tanto qué te parece si lo sustituimos me
va a quedar que menos 4 por equis pero x
vale 2 x 2 ok esto más 2 veces y es
igual a 12
ok creo que cambia de color vamos a
ponerlo todo con el mismo color ok y
cuantos 4 por 2 bueno 4 x 2 es 8 por lo
tanto me va a quedar
8 - 82 y esto es igual a 12 y ahora qué
te parece si nosotros sumamos 8 de ambos
lados de esta ecuación más 8 más 8 eso
lo podemos hacer y nos va a quedar
entonces lo siguiente estos dos se van
solamente me queda dos veces y dos veces
y es igual a 12 más 8 lo cual es 20 ok y
ahora qué te parece si para finalizar
dividimos todo entre 2 dividimos esta
parte entre 2 dividimos esta parte entre
2 para despejar la x este y este se va a
ir me va a quedar que james y es igual a
20 entre 2 lo cual es 10 de lujo ya
también tengo el valor de james x es
igual a 2 y es igual a 10 y parece ser
que ya tenemos la solución de este
problema para estar completamente
convencidos que te parece si
corroboramos en las dos ecuaciones que
tengo aquí arriba así que vamos a
comprobar
vamos a comprobar y aquí me quedaría
menos 4 x x pero x baleados entonces
esto es menos 8 más dos veces más dos
veces ya pero lleva les 10
entonces me quedaría más 20 o dejamos
cambiar este color
+ 20 esto tiene que ser igual a 12 y
bueno menos 8 más 20 en efectos 12 por
lo tanto si sirve para la primera
ecuación vamos a ver si sirve también
para la segunda ecuación menos 5 veces x
menos 5 por 2 es menos 10 menos 10 menos
dos veces james menos dos por diez es
menos 20 ok esto tiene que ser igual al
menos 30 y bueno eso también es cierto
menos 10 menos 20 pues es menos 30 por
lo tanto también sirve para la segunda
ecuación ya que comprobamos si estamos
completamente seguros que las soluciones
están x igualdad 2 llegó a la 10 qué te
parece si ahora la escribimos aquí en la
página de internet perfecto
vamos a abrir la página del navegador y
voy a poner que x vale 2 y vale 10
comprobar respuesta ai de lujo estamos
bien